there is an update this morning to our
CBS News investigation into complaints
over carbon monoxide in Ford Explorers
the Center for auto safety is urging
Ford Motor Company to recall more than
1.3 million explorers now this comes
just days after Ford announced that its
offering free inspections and repairs to
reduce the potential for exhaust
standard vehicles but the company
insists this it's explorers are safe and
they said the offer was quote for a
customer's peace of mind Kris Van Cleave
is outside Atlanta Georgia with the
latest on this story Chris good morning
good morning the Center for auto safety
is calling on Ford to recall all of its
2011 to 2017 Ford Explorer SUVs this is
something we've been reporting on for
months now the National Highway Traffic
Safety Administration is investigating
more than 2,700 complaints about
possible carbon monoxide seeping into
the cabin of Ford Explorers that
includes reports of 41 injuries and
three accidents that may also be linked
in July police in Austin test it Texas
parked more than 400 Explorers after
nearly two dozen officers were found to
have carbon monoxide in their blood
across the country Ford has been
repairing the Explorer police cruisers
at no cost but the company says the
issues are separate from the complaints
in civilian models and are due to
modifications of the vehicles after they
were purchased like installing emergency
lights now responding to the call for a
recall Ford says the company is
confident in our current methods for
quickly identifying and addressing
potential vehicle issues so instead of a
recall Ford will be sending letters to
owners of 2011 to 2017 Ford Explorers
encouraging them to bring their vehicles
into dealerships for inspections and
possible repairs Jeff Chris thank you
very much